mr elliott joe bike from sky news are
you offering access to your uncle for
money mr elliott this is ben elliott one
of the best connected men in the country
he's co-chairman of the conservative
party in charge of raising millions from
tory donors he's the nephew of the
prince of wales and the duchess of
cornwall accused of selling access to
the future king although there is no
suggestion prince charles was aware
there are other members who
who just use us because we're the best
at getting sporting tickets and he's the
founder of quintessentially a concierge
service for the super rich he's
described himself as a willing slave to
the stars
do you think it's appropriate that you
have seemingly been taking money for
access to prince charles
mohammed mercy knows ben elliot's charms
the telecoms millionaire turned
philanthropist is currently embroiled in
corruption claims
i have never ever acted dishonestly or
within proprietary at any point in time
but over the last four years he and his
partner have donated 750 000 pounds to
the tories he has been a member of
quintessentially and met both boris
johnson and prince charles
he remains loyal to the party and its
leader but is concerned about conflicts
of interest
if there were lepsis then i think the
best thing the party could do or should
do is to convene a special
investigation do you think ben elliot
should remain in his job
he's done a great job in terms of
raising money for the party
the party has to see the board has to
see whether he is somebody that is
willing and able to work within those
strictures and the answer to that is yes
give him a chance if the answer to that
is no
then perhaps some invite him to
reconsider his position
labour argue ben elliot should go this
is cronyism and sleaze at the heart of
government and the conservatives should
be rooting it out
rather than doubling down and promoting
it
a conservative party spokesperson said
ben elliott's business and charitable
work are entirely separate to the
voluntary work he does for the party
donations the conservative party are
properly and transparently declared to
the electoral commission published by
them and comply fully with the law
of course every party needs donations
with labour it's largely from the trade
unions the conservatives rely on
business people but the suggestion here
is not just that if you have the money
you can meet some of the most powerful
people in the country but that one of
the most senior figures in the tory
party is mixing his personal political
and business interests
you've been criticized for seemingly
having conflict of interest between
different roles you hold within the
conservative party you're closer to the
royal family is it appropriate
ben elliott remains in post it seems the
prime minister is loath to lose his
fundraising talents joe pike sky news
manchester